[Música]
i
en el último día de la convención
demócrata se espera el discurso de
aceptación del candidato por el partido
para la presidencia de los eeuu así como
su fórmula vicepresidencial kamala
harris va a ir en será el encargado de
dar el cierre a estos cuatro días de
convención una convención única como
ninguna otra en medio de una pandemia
que tuvo que hacerse de manera virtual
con más de 1000 vídeos grabados con
anticipación por parte del partido
demócrata se espera que bailen muestren
en este extenso discurso cuál será su
plataforma cuáles serán los temas más
importantes en materia de recuperación
económica en medio de la pandemia de
desempleo de inmigración de justicia
social de justicia racial entre otros
temas centrales que hemos visto durante
estos últimos cuatro días también se
esperan testimonios de ciudadanos que se
han visto afectados por las políticas
del presidente donald trump
[Música]
pues llegamos a la última jornada de una
convención demócrata histórica por la
pandemia en la que nos encontramos que
precisamente ha provocado que aquí en
nueva yor estos días se hayan vivido de
una manera descafeinada precisamente en
una ciudad donde más del 80% de la
población es demócrata hemos echado de
menos la propaganda del partido en las
calles a los corralillos de ciudadanos
discutiendo los diferentes discursos que
hemos visto estos días y es que el
coronavirus ha hecho que todos los
neoyorquinos sigan esta convención desde
los salones de su casa desde allí
también han participado los 346
delegados de nueva york muchos de ellos
han recogido momentos estelares en estas
cuatro jornadas como por ejemplo el
senador chuck schumer o la legisladora
alexandra ocasio cortes que participaba
en el primer día de convención así
también el gobernador del estado de
nueva york andrew como que también lo
veíamos en este primer día o el ex
alcalde de la ciudad michael bloomberg
que hará su discurso realizará su
discurso en la jornada de hoy
[Música]
la convención demócrata llegó a su
máximo nivel para los californianos pues
tuvo una fuerte representación de este
estado dorado en la convención demócrata
que se lleva a cabo en línea primero
nancy pelosi la gran opositora en el
senado el presidente dona throne muchos
querían ver lo que dijeran y bueno
quedaron un poco satisfechos con las
palabras de la veterana senadora otra
senadora también representando a las
mujeres californiana si en este caso las
afroamericanas kamala harris que es la
fórmula vicepresidencial para joe biden
y muchos querían verla ya con esta aura
presidenciable que le da la convención y
finalmente la aparición del presidente o
ex presidente barack obama que tiene
muchísimos seguidores en california y
aunque muchos fue la crítica que se hizo
hoy en la mañana muchos piden caras
nuevas dentro del partido demócrata son
las caras veteranas de este partido las
que siguen haciendo presencia en esta
convención
[Música]